THEY'VE ALWAYS BEEN SO
SUPPORTIVE.
>> GO FLY.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
EVERY AMERICAN IS BORN WITH
INHERENT RIGHTS, THAT'S WHAT OUR
FOUNDING DOCUMENTS SAY.
AND THE PURPOSE OF THE AMERICAN
GOVERNMENT IS TO PROTECT THOSE
RIGHTS WHICH HAS BEEN OUR
NATIONAL CREATE FOR HUNDREDS OF
YEARS, AND IT'S WORKED.
FOR THE LEFT NO LONGER BELIEVES
THAT.
THE LEFT HAS DECIDED THE
BILL OF RIGHTS ONLY APPLIES TO
PEOPLE WHO AGREE WITH THEM AND
THE SECOND AMENDMENT COVERS
THEIR SECURITY DETAIL.
YOU CAN'T BE TRUSTED TO HAVE A
GUN AT HOME.
NOW THE ACTIVIST LAUGHS TELL US
THAT PEOPLE WHO DISAGREE WITH
THEM NO LONGER HAVE MOVEMENT FOR
ASSOCIATION.
LEAVE THEIR HOMES THEY WILL BE
SURROUNDED BY MOBS AND A FRIEND.
LAST FRIDAY, SARAH HUCKABEE
SANDERS WERE FORCED TO LEAVE A
RESTAURANT BECAUSE THE OWNER
DIDN'T LIKE THE POLITICS.
SANDERS AND HER HUSBAND WENT
HOME BUT THE REST OF THE FAMILY
WENT TO ANOTHER RESTAURANT.
BEING RELATED TO SOMEONE WHO
WORKS AT THE WHITE HOUSE SO THEY
CONTINUE TO HARANGUE THEM AS
THEY CONTINUE TO EAT.
PROTESTERS HAVE AMASSED OUTSIDE
OF THE HOME OF WHITE HOUSE AIDE
TO STEPHEN MILLER.
IN CASE THEIR INTENTIONS WEREN'T
CLEAR ENOUGH, THEY PUT UP MARK
A DHS EMPLOYEE MEANWHILE FOUND A
BURN TO COME UP DECAPITATED
ANIMAL CARCASS ON HIS FRONT
PORCH.
THE MESSAGE IS CLEAR, ACTIVISTS
ON THE LEFT ARE MOVING TOWARD
APPLAUDED.
A PIECE YESTERDAY IN "SPLINTER
NEWS" WHICH IS THE OWNED BY
UNIVISION, THAT'S BOTH JUST THE
MINIMUM BASELINE HERE."
HOW EXTREME?
THE ARTICLE FONDLY RECALLS THE
DOMESTIC TERROR BOMBINGS OF THE
1970s.
THOUSANDS PER YEAR IN AMERICA,
THAT'S OUR FUTURE, THE ARTICLE
SAYS.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE ARE HEADED
THERE FAST.
CONGRESSWOMAN MAXINE WATERS
PURGED OF THE MOB TO HUNT DOWN
AND FIND MEMBERS OF THE
>> IF YOU -- YOU HAVEN'T SEEN
ANYTHING YET.
YOU HAVE MEMBERS OF YOUR CABINET
THAT ARE BEING BOOED OUT OF
RESTAURANTS.
PROTESTERS ARE TAKING ABOUT
THEIR HOUSE.
THEY ARE GETTING NO PEACE, NO
SLEEP.
NO PEACE, NO SLEEP.
LET'S MAKE SURE WE SHOW UP
WHEREVER WE HAVE TO SHOW UP AND
IF YOU SEE ANYBODY FROM THAT
STATION, YOU GET OUT AND YOU
FORM A CROWD AND YOU PUSH BACK
ON THEM.
YOU TELL THEM THEY ARE NOT
WELCOME ANYMORE, ANYWHERE.
>> Tucker: MAXINE WATERS ISN'T
JUST ANY MEMBER OF CONGRESS,
"THE DAILY BEAST" CALLS HER "A
FOLK HERO."
"BUZZFEED" CALLS FOR THE NEW
UNFAZED CHALLENGE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SHE IS ALSO A CIVIL RIGHTS
LEADER WHICH MAKES IT A LITTLE
WEIRD THAT SHE'S DEMANDING
CERTAIN PEOPLE BE DENIED PUBLIC
ACCOMMODATIONS.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT SHE'S SAYING
AND SHE SAID IT AGAIN YESTERDAY.
>> I STAND BY MY SPEECH, AND
SAYING THAT THE PROTESTS HAVE
CONSIDERS THE POLITICAL
OPPONENTS FELLOW CITIZENS OR EAT
EVEN HUMAN.
HOW LONG UNTIL THEY START OPENLY
CALLING FOR SOMETHING BAD TO
HAPPEN TO THOSE APPOINTMENTS?
IN THE CASE OF MAXINE WATERS, IT
WON'T BE THE FIRST TIME.
IN 1992, WATERS CHEERED AS A
RACIST MOBS BURNED IN
LOS ANGELES.
WHEN REGINALD DENNY WAS DRAGGED
FROM HIS TRUCK AND NEARLY
MURDERED FOR THE COLOR OF HIS
SKIN, BEATEN WITH A CINDER BLOCK
IN THE HEAD ON CAMERA, WATERS
PARTIED WITH THEM AFTER HIS
WASHINGTON KNOWS THAT AND
DEMOCRATS DON'T CARE.
CHUCK SCHUMER DID CALLED WATERS
IN HIS MOST RECENT REMARKS "NOT
AMERICAN," GOOD FOR HIM.
THAT WAS THE THEME.
>> I FEEL THAT THIS IS SIMILAR
TO NAZI GERMANY.
THE TOTALITARIAN BEHAVIOR IS
SHOCKING AND HORRENDOUS.
WE HAVE TO BE VIGILANT.
>> THEY FOLLOW THE EXACT PATTERN
THAT HAS OR HAS, HE IS EVIL.
AND AT THE THING IS, I THOUGHT I
WILL COME IN AND HE WOULDN'T
REALLY KNOW BECAUSE HE HAS TO DO
HIS SHOWMANSHIP THING, BUT HE'S
EVIL.
>> THIS IS PURE AND SIMPLE RACE,
RACISM, THAT'S ALL THIS IS.
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT HIM ARE
FRIGHTENED TO DEATH OF THIS
COUNTRY BECOMING THE BROWNING OF
INTERESTING IS HAPPENING.
AS PROGRESSIVES BECOME MORE
AUTHORITARIAN AND LESS,
TOLERANT, THEY SEEM MORE
CONVINCED THAT THEY ARE FIGHTING
ACTUAL RATHER THAN THEIR FELLOW
AMERICANS.
THE MORE THEY ACCUSED THE
ADMINISTRATION OF EXTREMISM, THE
ONCE YOU DECIDE THAT THE PEOPLE
WHO DISAGREE WITH YOU ARE NAZIS,
EVERYTHING IS ALLOWED.
THIS COULD VERY WELL END IN
TRAGEDY, SOME PROGRESSIVE SEEMED
TO WELCOME ALL THAT.
SUPPORTS DEMOCRATS.
IT IS SAYS THEY ARE ACCOMPLICES.
THIS IS THE LANGUAGE OF TOTAL
WAR.
IT'S SCARY, NO PLACE IN
POLITICS.
THE ONLY PLACE THAT CAN STOP IT
ARE THE ADULTS ON THE LEFT.
THERE ARE STILL SOME DEMOCRATIC
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, AND MEDIA
CHIEFTAINS LIKE JEFF ZUCKER AT
CNN OR ANTI-LAC AT CNBC.
THEY ARE COWERING AND COMPLICIT
IN ALL OF THIS BUT THE COUNTRY
BADLY NEEDS THEM TO COOL THE
CHANNELS.